what up guys just picked up the little
monkey dude from school
and you guys noticed something oh that
laugh
that's grandpa
grandpa moved in with us and he's
actually been living with us all week
and it's been super cuny he comes every
single day to pick up taika and he gets
to see all his antics him dancing around
and making all the teachers laugh and he
just loves it
huh do you like uh do you like grandpa
picking you up
are you sure
oh i don't know
all right now we're on our way to show
my dad his house which he'll be seeing
for the very first time and i'm excited
are you excited i'm super excited
what's going on has he not even gone
through the
the walk through the model homes he's
been through the model homes okay okay
cool i was just like whoa not even that
yeah that part was important to me so
you guys can watch those vlogs where uh
we walk through the model homes and my
dad walked through because i wanted to
make sure that he really likes it
because you know he is moving from one
state to another state and he's probably
gonna be in this house for the rest of
his life so i just want to make sure
everything was good and i showed him a
bunch of model homes actually we
actually have an entire real estate tour
of like two bedroom three bedroom homes
just specifically for
the grandpa back there but yeah we we
finalized on this one it was really good
price
close to a bunch of asian supermarkets
was perfect for my pop-up and uh we
paid the money and now they're building
it and you guys saw the vlog where um
they're putting all the frames up but
yeah he'll be seeing it for the first
time that's super cute is this his first
like brand new home
i believe so bye-bye
so my dad can't really hear let me let
me ask him off camera and i'll tell you
guys
all right so i just talked to my dad i
have to scream at him literally because
then he can't hear that well but yeah he
said the last house he had in california
um was brand new and i remember when he
got it it was a hundred and seventy
grand
and my dad just sold his house for seven
like thirty seven forty or something
like that i've been obviously been
living there for 20 years but that's a
crazy come up
so that this won't be his first new new
house cuny but this one is up to date
with all the new new stuff i give him
props because to like uproot at his age
start all over
it's pretty scary it is right it's
pretty damn scary because even me like i
mean i wasn't really scared
but it's definitely a big adjustment you
know and we know like older people they
once they're set in their ways
they don't want to shake too much [ __ ]
up because it's just so daunting and
like
terrifying you know your dad's barely
learning how to use the iphone he got
lost yesterday i think
he did was he not using the maps yeah so
my dad doesn't really know how to use
the navigation that well
so i was trying to teach him and i even
stored it i was like bank
taika school home so he could just like
go on maps and click but he doesn't know
how to use it that well so i actually
wrote out the directions in chinese on a
piece of paper
um for him to like walk you right
charlie i do write chinese that's
awesome and then so i wrote on a piece
of paper so you can go to the bank
and uh what's so cuny is i'm so glad we
have our location sharing on
wait a second monkey oh what this is
crazy hair dude
[Music]
yeah so um what was cuny is we have our
location sharing thing on and so i can
see him on that little dot going further
and further and further away from our
house which is cuny and then he ended up
calling me and he was like hey i think
i'm i'm uh
i'm lost i'm like oh you guys like that
oh you just got to go the other way
you're like dud i've been watching you
go the opposite way for like the past 10
minutes dad well i don't know if he was
going towards like chinatown oh yeah you
didn't know what it was on his agenda
but in my mind it's funny to go like
he's lost and you see him going further
further up yeah but yeah but props to my
pops though props to my damn
props to my pops because yeah he just
uprooted everything like literally this
whole week he's just been trying to just
establish his roots he's like okay
where's that chinese bank because i make
with this chinese make i know there's
one out here have to go find that so
he's finding that now uh tomorrow he's
gonna go try to find his doctors i have
to write all of his um
directions in chinese for a doctor and
then the week after that he's gonna be
doing like the dmv stuff so he's just
getting literally all his roots stuff in
because you know when you move into a
new place like a lot of these things you
kind of just take for granted and my dad
having the language barrier he's still
down to do it so i'm so proud of him
props to the pups
are you excited he goes huh i'm like are
you happy are you getting a new house he
goes
do i really gotta wait until october
this straight asian dad style where he
just bulldozes the conversation
excited
what do you want out of me he's like let
me just keep it real it's not like i
never lived in the new house before
it's so funny
about doesn't either
that's my dad if he likes it or not he's
like there's not if you like it or not
he's like once you're done then you'll
know what's going on
because i don't know what's going on
here
[Music]
if you're admiring my dad's fresh white
tea
that's because we just got him a whole
brand new pack at target yesterday
because he said he was getting fat so he
had a bunch of mediums and he was
stretching the [ __ ] out of them so we
got some brand new ones and large so
it's clean
my dad's asking
where the bedroom is
like a typical asian dad you know what's
so funny
like asian dads are the king of finding
problems so instead of enjoying the
moment he comes in and goes wait so
you're telling me i gotta build my own
backyard i'm like yeah that's how all
new builds are you have to build your
own backyard yo man i'm like don't worry
it's not gonna be a big deal
instead of enjoying the moment it's so
weird
they took us a master bathroom
my dad's like is this like a suite i'm
like yeah so this is we're in the master
bedroom right now
walk-in closet
closet
yeah closet so my dad has a walk-in
closet right here which is super nice
and then my dad's uh
master super nice got two big old
windows
and then if you walk through here this
is the
master bathroom
which is pretty big
oh i believe it's his and hers there
might be a her closet and in his closet
and then you have a separate toilet area
for privacies
is pretty hooked up
that's pretty hooked up
[Music]
i asked my dad i was like do you like it
or not and then he was like i don't know
if i like it or not we gotta wait till
we finish
and then i can imagine it because i
guess right now he can't imagine it just
looks like wood to him
which i think is fair because i think um
me and geo have seen so many houses and
so many faces
and so many model homes just by seeing
the frames up i can imagine
what the house is going to look like the
finishes and everything and my dad has
been living in one house the last 20
something years so when he's seeing just
regular frames go up he's like i can't
picture anything and he hasn't been
going to model homes he doesn't really
know what the finish is like the tile
the counter the carpet what all of
that's gonna look like so i completely
understand so
i feel like when uh the house is
actually done done
my dad is gonna be
letting out a lot more emotions and
happier
than he is right now i think he's still
in a state of like did i really move to
vegas
he's doing some advanced stuff
now yours isn't that good
what's yours it's yours
that is complicated
you're doing an open hi-hat do you know
what open hi-hat is
yeah
don't we all yeah red blue open hi not
monkey one two
a closed hi-hat is this it goes like
this it goes
and then open
open hi-hat goes
he opened it good job
see
it's good i can't do that
okay
oh man we gotta change that shirt
how much spit is on the back of that
chair
of yours not that much it's all on its
chest
hey taika look what i found
did you make those
oh that's cool you made binoculars can
you see
oh no it broke
that's so cool
on this cutie pie
time to get some snacks yeah healthy
stuff healthy snacks banana bread
but you want banana bread that's so
specific dude
why you keep scratching and taking your
clothes off dude you look you look crazy
you like it from l.a
this is a pretty cuny site our family
keeps growing and growing
but not with younger members with older
members
we got a little asian guy in the front
mexican in the middle and the old asian
guy in the back
with some
chunk felizies
look at that cuny family
i feel like we don't match at
all so we're trying to get him a healthy
snack
because yesterday we made the big
mistake of getting swedish fish and a
slurpee and he was bouncing off the
walls and as a four-year-old it's
already really hard to pay attention
because all it takes is like someone
tugging at your key now you want to tug
back or someone squeeze your cheek and
squeeze back so it's really easy to get
distracted and whoa you scared me
and it's really easy to like fall into
just having fun
right because no one wants to be like
the disciplined boy in class
and add a whole layer of sugar on top of
that he was just like just going up and
down up and down everyone was sitting up
and down he's like pulling out his ski
and he was just going crazy as if like
he drank like three
big old oh i'm so sorry and it was
almost like he was drinking like three
uh big old big old hands of red bull
so we're like yesterday we
decided to have a pact of normal oh who
scared me
no that's the stuff you can't eat
cause that's the stuff that gets you in
trouble
[Music]
what did you say
oh yeah there are a lot of fruits in
there
yes
are you kidding me this guy is a
salesman
it has fruits mama look you see the
picture
you see that it has fruits
that's what i used to do this guy's the
best literally my mom would be like stop
selling it to me put it in the car
already come on yes that's cute i'm like
mom i gotta get this barbie because now
like all the other barbers i had look it
has a rubber grip he's got this this and
i would like list out all the stuff that
it had i was like all right stop
pitching it to me just put it in the car
and i'm like
it doesn't make sense damn
that's crazy i think i was gonna see
this monkey but i think this is mango
but there's no mango yes
dude how do you expect the country to
stay lean
if it costs so much
to eat healthy that that fruit snack is
probably a dollar too
so you go a dollar or two with something
with extreme flavor or 13
day
i know you want watermelon but not that
one
is that what is that called the palette
dance
hey no no you're gonna get hurt dudey
what's good
pineapple and um
oh yeah i got that one that looks good
yeah i look delicious i was looking for
fruits that i don't typically eat we
have a whole ass pineapple at our house
by the way oh true
but when it's not cut open like that i'm
not prone to eating them
because you're lazy i am i am i'm so
sorry
this guy has endless energy with zero
snacks
yeah let's go
hey
relax
yeah you're in a public place dude
hey let me see your yummy lollipop duty
hey healthy snacks
that's cutie and someone stole mine
you guys are wasting food no he drunk
that's all yet she do it i saw him no i
saw you i saw you
are you a tiger i think so only tigers
make those kind of noises
you threw it again i know my mouse
throws that one and i drop that one okay
gotta be careful you can't be wasting
food like that okay
but it was because it was like it looked
weird uh
what's with the sticks for dude
so we did attempt to give him
no sugar
but he's still got
endless energy
i think he's gonna have a good class
what do you think
hey stop
bumping into her already and just look
at all that matt's face well i'm i'm
happy because she's going to whoop her
ass i hope
she looks because she's good she's
really good
taika
leave her alone
the defeated parent
this is so cuny i don't know the last
time my dad made me food
even though it's frozen dumplings
he's still cuny because it was his idea
he was like hey do you guys like
dumplings and i was like you know who
loves dumplings
taika
do you know
who loves dumplings
oh yeah
i know you love dumplings
so so cuny that grandpa is making
dumplings
for our cutie little family
huh
look at that my dad already got the
water boiling
through the dumplings in there
my dad said he went to the supermarket
and bought all the sauces like vinegar
chili
soy sauce and he even made a whole plate
of corn you want some corn
put some butter on there
what else you can mix again yep
mayo
no what do you put not tahini no oh
what's that powder they put on there
there just chili flakes
cheese no they put a like a red powder
on there
what is that just chili flakes red
powder
like father like son
there's no one else
eating or anything
but here you two are that's cute
you take a picture for us actually
that's really funny
[Music]
my dad's so deaf he's so deaf he wants
me to eat the pork yeah he wants to eat
corn so bad i'm gonna eat the car you
know what's hilarious dude what so we're
at the supermarket right and then he
bought the corn and i know my dad's on a
diet so i was like i'm not gonna tell
him because he's just like getting
situated this week
i know and then uh once he got it and
went into the car i was like hey dad let
you know i know you're on diet um
i don't think you should have the corn
yeah unless you want to or just eat half
yeah and then he was like all right you
know what i'm just not gonna eat it i'll
make it for you guys right so he he
steamed it
and then once he saw me put the butter
the latte on there he was like
[ __ ] it and he grabbed one that's when
he ate it over the
sink has the same impulses as i do did
you tell them about the chips oh yeah i
told you about the chips
these chips there's these two
yeah my daddy's on a diet right but
apparently
he's been uh i'll see him snacking on
this i'm like yeah don't you write on a
diet and he says
wait i thought that was a tomato
that's cheese on there
that's not butter
that with the elote trader joe seasoning
is actually pretty good okay excuse me
you can't be married to a mexican it's
not authentic they call it
all right
it
well guess what try this try this
damn it try this on precise try this on
for sizes
don't cuss in front of my son please
after you say in chinese
bye
my dad's such an asian dad i was like i
took him to see the house right i'm like
hey dad are you happy it's a brand new
house and he's like it's all right
and i was like do you like it do you
like the rooms he was like i can't tell
until it's finished
that's tight i know
can i just take this plate yeah just
take it
no leave it and just only take the coin
i'm like who's yeah who's played into
this it's a funny dysfunctional family
dinner
we have a british lady
a old asian man in here a mexican with
blonde hair this is like a [ __ ] joke
this is a joke this is where the joke
begins it's like a 90s racist joke
mia
well that was extremely cuny
having our little family get together
with my
pops taika's grandpa and uncle joe
i can hear taika having a blast
wow
are you butt naked
oh okay oh my god
i'm so fat mama
just coming up the stairs i'm running
out of breath i know
oh i see it
you do
yeah that means i gotta get bigger
shirts so you don't see my fat but then
how are you gonna ever recognize your
baby
oh my beep is big baby
don't say pee pee what a good boy
since taika and grandpa are going to be
hanging out way more i want to help
taika with this chinese
so i didn't know if these things existed
but i googled like chinese english
children's books
children's books and two of them came up
on amazon so i've bought these in case
you guys are going through the same
problem not even a problem but just the
same circumstance and i feel like since
there's so many chinese american first
second third generation i feel like this
is a very common circumstance so this
one's called the great race and i get to
teach taika about the zodiac
while teaching him like english and
chinese which is super cool
and it's a hardcover wow look at that
it's a whole sudo which means the last
one is the pig
nice
and then this one is called
mama's home in taiwan which ironically
is tight because
my mom's home is in taiwan and it's
called mama tsai taiwan the [ __ ]
pretty cool huh
yeah this is the 101 building this is
the tallest building in taiwan i saw you
there you saw me there yeah and mama oh
you did i thought
yeah i haven't supposed to say dad in
spanish it's spanish we're learning
chinese
oh chinese
your pronunciation is so good it was
like papa yeah good job
look at this
took the high speed train too i called
you like like mama like monkey papa
that's what i call you that is that's
what chinese took the high speed train
to kaushong
you've been to gaucho
with school show that's where it's the
city that's where grandma lives
yeah we want them it's a city like los
angeles yeah our childhood sacramento
sacramento it's a city our
look at this kind of
technical
did you know that taiwan is actually the
indigenous people are polynesian
no
well now you know
and that usually means his focus time is
over and we'll have to save it for
another day
no he's still in it really are you in it
yeah
okay cute this guy's comedic timing is
impeccable
whoa look at that's a big party whoa
that's a lot of people my favorite thing
to do is go to the night market with my
cousins
to every delicious fun install do you
want to know how to say
your cousins
no in chinese
it's bialka if they're older
and beyond b if they're younger
oh the older like not like like like
christopher though yeah yeah that's
beyond good yeah
hi
come on the little
we fish they go to night market do you
want to say fish
unknown
good job
that's a
mouth twister it is all the arcade games
play marbles and games together
do you know how to say
play games
[Music]
yeah so if you tell your yeah why yoshi
then he knows to play games with you
you say
one yoshi go like this
one
yeah and that means grandpa i want to
play games
player
yeah that's groundhog yeah and that's
kids yeah
look at this we eat q balls popcorn
chicken that's delicious red bean cakes
oh i like lamb i like cake you know how
you say uh red bean cake
cake
if you see grandma and you go can i have
some tango she'll get you some cake
but careful she might get the healthy
stuff that's not very good yeah she
might give you the pineapple stuff but
oh the butt whoa whoa the pineapple
stuff is bomb do you like that one oh
yeah okay
boba
bubble tea and shave ice
beauty this is this is shave ice
remember when we get shave ice
you know what that's called no swapping
swapping what life lightweight why you
pop why you put cream that's healthy
yeah why you're so smart learning so
much and we also visit lots of really
convenient
stuff at china store it's a china store
yeah or
a chinese dollar you know how do you say
store
you're so cute and smart
whoa look at all the luggage
i love it you say luggage luggage is
shingly
yeah
that's so cool huh yeah yeah yeah that's
you you're a good job that's you right
there
okay
and that's that's mom
and that's your grandma
nine-nine
but he doesn't wear glasses
no he doesn't only sometimes
yeah i would be bad to her you're going
to be bad to her i always do that
oh that's me ask me yeah
i enjoyed it
that's the that's the girl from the uh
polynesian place but he's my friend yeah
hey wait don't touch my nipples here
look i like mama's home i love taiwan
yeah that's it
read it
yeah we'll read it tomorrow we'll read
it again and we got another book
i don't want to miss my time what are
you talking about did you know mandarin
is one of the most spoken languages in
the world spanish is also yeah you're
not and then tell them the one spanish
word you still know what's the worst
memories
what is it say something in spanish
i bet you i know it
there it is
there
that means good night good night
everyone as much as
oh